[Musik]
hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem weiteren
ford night video hier auf meinem kanal
fragt mich nicht was für beschissen dass
kinder das vor einigen tagen ist die
neue fordern als diesen neuen
rausgekommen ein ganz ganz viele von
euch hell mein lieblings vor neid
spieler luca muss dazu unbedingt ein
video laden
daher werden wir auf jeden fall gleich
anfangen zum zocken die sache ist
allerdings ihr seht hier schon das ist
einen fkk all das hier ist die skala aus
fortnight die goldene skadi ist hier
eher gelb aber okay das video hier ist
nicht gesponsert also ich bekomme kein
geld für das ich hier irgendwie euch das
ding hier zeige allerdings also ich habe
keine ahnung ob dieses teile so richtig
party schief wenn man selber gegen die
brust
ok mal schauen ob ich noch ein
buchstaben runter schießen kann ich
leider dinge immer wieder komplett auf
mit neun patronen
wir werden es in dieser heutigen folge
einfach mal so machen dass ich jetzt
noch mal fordert zocken werde hier mit
diesem keine ahnung immer noch was das
für beschissen das kinn ist wir spielen
komplett normal eine runde fortnight
solo und jedes mal wenn ich sterbe also
in der sommerrunde dementsprechend
einmal das heißt wir spielen mehrere
solo runden heute und jedes mal wenn ich
sterbe also jedes mal nach einer runde
weil ich glaube gewinnen werde ich so
circa gar keine sobald ich sterbe wird
die jugend was ist das hier eigentlich
ist das auch wir sind
wir schauen uns erst mal an was hier neu
dazu gewählt haben mag jesu gehen wir
gleich in der runde hin jetzt springen
wir erstmal bei nero tötet raus das soll
wohl sonne zukunftsstadt sein oder
irgendwie sowas wir sehen hier schon da
fliegen das sind so zeppeline die hier
drüberfliegen hat es ist alles so ein
bisschen future mäßig aber auf jeden
fall werde nach jedem tod von mir darf
jule mich abknallen mit dieser waffe
also das wird heute so ein bisschen die
challenge okay das ist sonst kann
also das ist natürlich mega geil ich
habe keine ahnung warum ich jetzt das
überhaupt mache ich brauche eigentlich
waffen wir sind auf jeden fall andere
leuchtmittel
hallo es geht hier um ein friedliches
miteinander juni hat gar nicht weg haben
das ist eigentlich echt ganz nice ich
also das ist also in zukunft mäßige
stadt m ich habe mich schon gefragt wann
das endlich mal auch einfordern
reinkommt normalerweise mag ich so
zukunft sachen nie so aber in freude mit
der grafik glaube ich könnte es echt
ganz cool werden die karten sind rauchen
als aus ich würde sagen in dieser runde
geben wir nochmal zu neo tötet weil wir
da vorhin nicht so lange überlebt haben
man sieht auf jeden fall dass dieser
luftkanal der geht quasi über die
komplette metal hier lang und geht auch
hier durch dieses neo tötet durch also
das ist auf jeden fall megageil also man
kommt jetzt wirklich von einem zum
anderen punkt auf der map viel viel viel
schneller die ganzen profi fordert
spieler die mir grad zuschauen werden
noch denkt ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung ich habe auch keine große ahnung
von dem spiel ich bin auch nicht der
beste spieler zu sein der beschlüsse
spieler ich habe ihn einmal getroffen
gut dass ich echt alles mega cool aus
ehrlich gesagt muss ich wirklich zugeben
ich will eigentlich ganz cool dann kann
ich das ding hier schon okay was sind
das alter ist natürlich in jedem fordert
video von mir sage bitte erwartet hier
keine übelsten skill place keine ahnung
was ich bin ein ziemlich schlechter
spieler hier ist die kiste war
hahahahaha das thema ich bin schlecht
dass wieder also dem bruder haben auf
jeden fall gut abgefertigt aber was ich
gerade sagen wollte ich bin kein guter
spieler ihr werdet hier keine tipps et
cetera kriegen sondern eher einen
heulkrampf und aggressionen also falls
das für euch völlig in ordnung ist dann
bleib doch gerne dran oder szabo da das
scheißegal jetzt bin ich wieder auf dem
dach erst mal ordentlich scheißen gehen
wir haben auf jeden fall auch einige
leute gekämpft und würden hier nicht so
viele sachen rum liegen
das heißt eventuell so bürger ich hätte
gern das eis da bitte wird bald
irgendwie wirkt tötet immer noch
ziemlich leergefegt ich weiß nicht ob
ich das so sehe da kommt ihr geschaffen
oh mein gott eine furt bombe die ein
auto scheint okay ich bin tot ja der hat
doch diesen krassen skin alltag lars der
gut aber ich hatte zwei kids in dieser
runde schule
jetzt würde ich sagen fliegen weil man
nicht dahin so tötet hände sind neo nach
vorne zu dieser von usern glaube ich
geschaffenen ort dingsbums das heißt
marquis youtube das gesicht das gesicht
bleibt stehen nicht töten wenn paar
sekunden später hat eine waffe was er
hat mich auch richtig hoch genommen
ja was ist dein problem ich glaube wenn
wir direkt dafür kriegen wir das auf
jeden fall ganz cool
das sieht aus wie so eine bösewicht
villa beziehungsweise irgendwie aus
einem james-bond-film hier steht halt
eine fette yacht wie bauen die leute
dann überhaupt sonne yachten fortnight
also ich weiß nicht ob ich einfach zu
blöd bin und nicht oh mein gott da ist
schon ein anderer ich versuche mich mit
ihm anzufreunden
das hat nicht so ganz geklappt
es geht schon los wir springen jetzt
einfach mal hier raus er mich mal wieder
am handy gehabt komplett verpasst das
ich hab den ton halt immer so leise ich
kriege auf jeden fall nie mit wenn wir
dann irgendwo losfliegen oder landen
oder keine ahnung was er mich jetzt
wieder so ein lava tunnel ich glaube
dass auch neue methode genau das ist ein
tunnel luca ich dachte erst mal wird ihn
wie hochgeschleudert wenn man da rein
springen aber okay
hier sind so komische geräusche überall
hätte ich weiß ehrlich gesagt bisher
noch nicht so richtig was ich von 79
halten soll
irgendwie ist es nicht mehr so ganz
fortnight finde ich klasse school mit
diesem neuen windkanal hier dass man
sogar oben fliegen kann und es ist auch
neu ist das teilte jetzt wieder so ein
bisschen attraktiver ist dadurch dass
doch wieder gebäude stehen
aber es ist halt nicht mehr so richtig
vor neid finde ich ich glaube das hat
man so circa bei jedem spiel mit der
zeit und zwar entwickelt sich es einfach
zu viel weiter fort und entwickeln sich
zu weit von dem weg wie man das spiel
selber lieben gelernt hat versteht was
ich meine
ich hab kein materialien
ok kultur wir fliegen jetzt wieder zu
dieser fehler aber ich schwöre euch
jetzt werde ich länger überleben
ja das wird jetzt erstmal ein langer
flug 2000 jahre später angekommen
wenn ich nicht mehr so um gucke ist uns
glaube ich keiner gefolgt also wir sind
die einzigen hier das heißt wir schauen
uns jetzt erstmal diese fette geile
villa an
wir gehen hier über den balkon rein und
es sieht schon stick aus überlegt wo
wohnst irgendwann so dass du okay du
hast nicht mehr fenster er ist ein
gegner wie sie aber gut freund ich habe
das ja nicht heute auch noch ein kleines
thema das ich euch mitteilen möchte
bevor das video jetzt irgendwann zu ende
gehe ich mal natürlich hole ich auch
noch den sieg gleich und zwar live
streaming meine damen und herren ich bin
von wem ist dieses ding aber gut fahre
mit diesen dingen einfach mal so ein
bisschen rum
ich war schon öfters mal um auf dieses
thema livestream zurückzukommen ich war
schon öfters mal auf instagram live das
waren aber er dann so streams wisst ihr
handy eine art paar fragen beantwortet
der stream gegen dann irgendwie 10 bis
20 minuten und in den letzten videos
habe ich euch dann auch schon öfters
davon erzählt dass ich dem nächsten mal
auf twitter anfangen möchte stream und
ich bin nun die partner keine ahnung wie
ich das geschafft hat das heißt ganz
einfach dass ich jetzt eigene emotes
habe also ich habe mit designerin mit
der lieben lina haben wir uns überlegt
dass eine kiste ich bin die kiste
schrott gefahren
wir haben uns kurz überlegt wir haben im
ort batches gemacht wir haben uns
animationen überlegt falls jemand neu
abonniert falls jemand geld spendet die
cetera pp und ich möchte euch einfach
nur sagen meine damen und herren an
diesem samstag jetzt samstag 20 uhr was
macht dieser scheiße balda am samstag um
20 uhr werde ich oft widge.de v
schrägstrich laser luca meinen ersten
richtigen ja live stream machen ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr einfach mal
am samstag um 20 uhr auf meinem twitch
kanal vorbeischauen werden
der film wird so ablaufen dass ich ihn
natürlich einerseits fragen beantworten
werde ich werde aber
mit euch lange zeit auf videos reagieren
habe ja schon länger nicht mehr auf
meinem kanal irgendwie auf rtl serien et
cetera reagiert hat werden wir alles im
stream machen also auf beispielsweise
hilft mir werde ich reagieren ich werde
auf andere youtuber reagieren ihr können
in der videos gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
ich werde fragen beantworten ich werde
sogar themen lager die euch
interessieren ich wär doch ford leid
spielen also da wird einiges geboten
sein werden tun der stream wird zu zwei
bis drei stunden dauern also ich werde
so von 8 bis 10 11 uhr live streamen
das heißt da könnt ihr jederzeit
vorbeischauen ich würde mich sehr freuen
wie bereits gesagt das ist mein erster
richtiger schritt
live stream als partner scheiße da
braucht sich direkt ein jahr von bruder
schild macht mal halblang jetzt hier
genau ja cool bist du an das heutige
zeit ist auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese fordert in den
real life teen challenge gefallen hat
dann das gerne einen daumen hoch unter
diesem video he daher findet unten in
der beschreibung meint rich profil also
twitch punkt tv schrägstrich laser luca
diesem samstag um 20 uhr wir dort mein
erster richtiger livestream kommen ich
hoffe ihr seid dabei mit am start
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
wie ihr die neue fortnight 79 findet
weil ich bin nicht so ganz begeistert
aber jetzt gewaltig druck
[Musik]